imagina que vamos caminando por la calle
y nos topamos si te digo hola verdine
cuál es el seno cual es el seno de pi
sobre 4 obviamente estamos trabajando
aquí con radiales y tal vez no tengas
memorizado ya sabes la respuesta y
dibujar un círculo unitario entonces lo
dibuja así se ve algo así aunque no tan
feo tal vez pero bueno aquí tienes la
idea y te ubicas en lo que es y sobre
cuatro radiales es lo mismo que 45
grados así que dibujas el radio en 45
grados y el cero está definido como la
coordenada jr
en el círculo unitario entonces sólo
queremos saber ese valor de ahí
inmediatamente tú dirías ok bueno aquí
tenemos 45 grados voy a dibujar de hecho
acá el triángulo un poco más grande para
que se note lo que estamos haciendo
entonces aquí lo tenemos 45 grados 45
grados y un ángulo recto aquí ahora
sabemos mucha información sobre
triángulos de 45 45 90 cierto la
hipotenusa mide 1 estos lados cada uno
mide x porque es un triángulo isósceles
miden lo mismo y ahora sólo queda hacer
un poco de álgebra entonces
tenemos x cuadrada más x cuadrada es
igual a 1 al cuadrado
así que 2x cuadrada es igual a 1 luego x
cuadrado es igual a un medio por lo
tanto x es igual a 1 sobre la raíz de 2
luego racionalizó esto multiplicando por
raíz de dos sobre raíz de dos y que
obtengo obtengo aquí esto es igual a
raíz de 2 sobre 2 eso es igual a x
entonces la altura aquí es de raíz de 2
sobre 2 y claro esta distancia también
me da lo mismo pero sólo nos importa la
altura porque es el valor del seno y el
seno el seno es esta bueno es solamente
esta altura la coordenada james y
obtuvimos raíz de 2 sobre 2 ahora todo
esto repaso aprendimos esto en el vídeo
del círculo unitario puedes darle un
vistazo si aún no lo has hecho pero
bueno supongamos que otro día nos
topamos yo te pregunto esta vez a ver
quiero que me digas cuál es el arco seno
de raíz de 2 sobre 2 y tú te quedas
sorprendido no te lo esperaba si tú
dices
no tengo ni la mínima idea tal vez tú
pienses bueno yo sé lo que es el seno de
raíz de dos sobre dos pero el arco seno
que es eso bueno el arco seno no tienes
la mínima idea pero cuando tú veas la
palabra arco al inicio de la palabra
quiere decir la inversa en este caso la
inversa del seno esto puede también ser
escrito como seno a la menos uno seno a
la menos uno de raíz de dos sobre dos es
la función inversa del seno a eso se
refiere todo lo que te está preguntando
es qué ángulo debo yo aplicarle la
función seno para obtener el valor de
raíz de dos sobre dos entonces dado que
se no la menos uno es lo mismo que el
arco seno aquí es la misma pregunta qué
ángulo debo tomar yo para aplicarle la
función seno y obtener raíz de dos sobre
dos yo podría entonces reescribir esto
cualquiera de estos dos argumentos bueno
de hecho deja lo hago así que esto lo
puedo escribir como como el seno de que
es igual a raíz de dos sobre dos y bueno
creo que es una mejor manera o una
manera más sencilla de formular esta
pregunta entonces el seno de que es
igual a raíz de 2 sobre 2
yo acabo de decir que el seno de pi
sobre 4 es raíz de 2 sobre 2 ajá
entonces en este caso yo sé que el seno
de pi sobre 4 es igual a raíz de 2 sobre
2 me pregunta o el signo de
interrogación es igual a pi sobre 4 o
puede escribirlo como el arco seno de
raíz de 2 sobre 2 es igual a pi sobre 4
entonces al coseno de raíz de 2 sobre 2
es igual a pis sobre 4 así que solo como
repaso te estoy te estoy dando un valor
y te pido que me des un valor que cuando
yo le aplique la función seno a ese
valor me da el valor que pido entonces
tú dices bueno espera un momento porque
pi sobre 4 funcionó 45 grados funcionó
pero yo podría seguir agregando 360
grados seguir agregando 2000 y todos
esos valores funcionarían bajan todos
funcionarían pero porque me lleven al
mismo punto del círculo unitario y estás
en lo correcto totalmente todos esos
valores tú creerás que son respuestas
correctas porque si tomas el seno de
cualquiera bueno de esas funciones
simplemente
sigues agregando 360 grados y obtienes
raíz de dos sobre dos así que bueno pero
ese es un problema porque no puedes
tener una función una función fx que una
función fx que mapea a diferentes
valores entonces bueno por ejemplo mapea
api sobre 4 y también a pi sobre 42 pi y
api sobre 4 + 4 pin así que para que
esto sea una función válida para que la
función inversa del seno sea realidad
debo restringir su rango vamos a
restringir su rango al punto más natural
entonces hagamos eso y bueno su dominio
aquí está restringido su dominio si yo
estoy tomando el arco seno de algo y
entonces si yo aplico el arco seno a xy
digo que es igual a theta entonces al
coseno de x es igual a tratar es dominio
aquí está restringido cuáles son los
valores válidos de x entonces x puede
ser igual a qué cosa
veamos si yo tomo el seno de cualquier
ángulo sólo puedo obtener valores entre
bueno cierto entonces x será mayor o
igual a menos 1 y menor o igual a 1
ese es el dominio para esta para que
esta función sea válida debo restringir
su rango los posibles valores para el
rango y para el arco seno la convención
es restringir lo al primero y cuarto
cuadrante del círculo unitario entonces
debo restringir los posibles valores a
esta área del círculo unitario esta área
de aquí entonces detalle está
restringido a ser menor o igual que pi
sobre 2 y mayor o igual que menos pi
sobre 2 y con esto a la mano bueno ya
sabemos lo que es el arco seno entonces
hagamos otro ejercicio otro ejercicio
con arco seno y digamos que te pregunto
esta vez cuál es el arco seno de menos
raíz de 3 sobre 2 entonces cuál es el
arco seno de menos raíz de 3
- raíz de 3 sobre 2 y tal vez no tengas
memorizado o tal vez no al menos bueno
al menos yo no lo tengo memorizado así
que hagamos este ejercicio y dibujo
nuevamente el círculo unitario cuando
estoy con el arco seno cuando trabajo
con el arco seno solo debo dibujar el
primero y el cuarto cuadrante mi eje de
lassie si mi eje de las equis y ahora
bueno donde estoy ubicada esta vez si el
seno de algo es de menos raíz de 3 sobre
2 entonces dónde estoy ubicada eso
quiere decir que la coordenada allí en
el círculo unitario es de menos raíz de
3 sobre 2 y por lo tanto más o menos
está por este punto esto es menos raíz
de 3 sobre 2 qué ángulo me da esto vamos
a pensar en esto un poco porque mi
coordenada y es menos raíz de 3 sobre 2
este es el ángulo será un ángulo
negativo el que se forma aquí cierto
porque estamos por debajo del eje de las
equis entonces voy a dibujar un pequeño
triángulo que se forma
aquí tenemos aquí se forma un pequeño
triángulo entonces aquí lo puedes ver
mejora con otro color bueno no está bien
así
este es el triángulo que se forma y
bueno lo voy a dibujar acá en grande
para tener más en claro lo que estoy
diciendo esto es teta y cuánto mide este
lado cuánto mide este lado eso mide lo
mismo que lo indicado por james raíz de
3 sobre 2 es negativo porque vamos hacia
abajo y ahora averigüemos cuánto mide
teta sabemos que es negativo cuando
vemos raíz de 3 sobre 2 espero
reconozcas que es un triángulo 30 y 60
90 este lado mide un medio y este lado
mide 1 porque es un círculo unitario por
supuesto su radio es uno y en el
triángulo 30 60 90 el ángulo opuesto al
lado que mide raíz de 3 sobre 2 es el
ángulo de 60 grados luego sabemos que
este ángulo mide 60 grados cierto su
magnitud va hacia abajo entonces
hablamos de menos 60 grados theta es
igual a menos 60 grados pero si estamos
en radiales
más multiplicar eso por irradian es
entonces aquí está mal es por ti radian
es sobre 180 grados los grados se
cancelan y nos queda que teta es igual a
menos pim sobre tres radiales y ya con
todo esto entonces podríamos decir
podemos ahora a hacer los argumentos que
el arco seno lo voy a escribir acá abajo
entonces el arco seno de menos raíz de
tres sobre dos es igual a menos pi sobre
tres radiales o podríamos decir que la
función inversa del seno de menos raíz
de tres sobre dos es igual a menos y
sobre tres radiales y para confirmar
esto voy a sacar la calculadora entonces
de hecho aquí está la calculadora y ya
lo tengo en modo de radiales ajá mira
aquí lo puedes ver ahí está en modo de
radiales
ahora quiero aplicar la función inversa
entonces oprimo segunda y después la el
botón de función seno entonces tengo
menos uno de menos raíz de tres raíz de
tres sobre dos esto es igual
- 1.04 como puedes ver entonces esto es
igual a menos 1.0 4 radiales y por lo
tanto pi sobre 3 debe ser igual a 1.04
veamos si puedo confirmar esto si
escribo si escribo aquí menos pi sobre 3
entonces
en efecto tengo lo mismo así que menos
piso sobre 13 es menos 1.04 y seno a la
menos uno de menos raíz de 3 sobre 2 es
también menos 1.04